kyle is with us in Raleigh North
Carolina hey Kyle welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show
I think say thanks for taking my call
sure what's up I'll just paint you a
quick picture I'm 29 years old got
20,000 in student loan debt so I'm
working on baby step two but when I was
young my parents took out a Gerber
life-insurance policy oh good lord
and so that's got like a face value of
ten thousand or death benefit of ten
thousand yeah and my mother gave me the
option a month or so ago if I wanted to
cash it out definitely the values like
$1500 yeah yeah it's a piece of crap
yeah bless her heart she's put she's put
a bazillion dollars into this thing and
it's worth $1,500 oh right I mean she
just got messed up bad I mean that yeah
if she had just put her money in a fruit
jar it'd be 15,000 right that's what
she's like this since you were born
I mean it's just horrible yeah cash it
out as quick as you can
okay can you are you single did you say
yes yeah I'm single
you know no kids or anything okay so
your need for life insurance is very low
right yeah the only time I might keep
crappy stuff like that is if you were
stuck in it because of health problems
your uninsurable to get other insurance
but you're able to get other insurance
and you know um besides that today you
probably have a very low need for it yes
definitely cash out freakin Gerber whole
life policies so um let me just kind of
give you guys that's that kind of brings
up something yeah I do this every so
often and I want to remind you okay his
mom meant well but if you'll take some
hints from the location or the brand of
the financial product you will know that
you're getting ripped off okay so if a
financial product for instance is being
advertised on cable television
right next to walk-in bathtubs and
self-insert catheters and Snuggies this
is what's known as a low-class
financial product this would be the gold
coin people this would be the reverse
mortgage people this would be what's the
Oh we'll get you out of all your income
tax debt right who else advertise
there's some other crappy thing the gold
the but if you just see it on cable TV
that tells you okay and here's the thing
you wouldn't buy your baby food from I
wouldn't buy my baby food food from
fidelity mutual fund company because
they're in the mutual fund business and
I wouldn't buy my financial products my
investments from my baby food company
hello I mean think about this you know
if these people are known for making
shoes I don't want to buy life insurance
from and if they're known for making
life insurance I don't wanna buy shoes
from you kind of get in the idea here
and so generally speaking you're low
class high ripoff financial products
financial opportunities financial fixes
whatever they are are put in areas that
give you a hint that it's low class you
credit life as an example okay if you're
gonna buy your life insurance from your
car dealer you're gonna get screwed
while you're buying your car they'll say
your life insurance it'll pay your car
off if you die I knew one guy bought a
rototiller for his garden financed it
and bought life insurance to make sure
that the rototiller freaking was paid
off of he died from the rototiller
people you might be a redneck if you
have life insurance on your rototiller
debt
seriously but that credit life what he
paid for that for that $7,000 or
whatever it was worth of insurance he
could about $700,000 worth of insurance
if he had just gone to Zander insurance
and priced out of term policy say think
about where who it is it's advertising
and where it's advertising and who it is
is selling it and it tells you it's
low-class it's bad stuff it's high
markup for ignorant people and they're
taking advantage of you this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]